so want to go across the pond god i knew
it i
recognized it right away recognized
stupid outfit like i know when it's like
real cops versus british ones
are you saying british cops are not real
no
they don't carry guns and they dress
like crossing guards
british cops are i don't even know like
i explain to me
maybe one of you british fans can
explain to me why do you even listen to
the cops over there
like what what can they really do to you
they dress like crossing guards they're
all like these
pasty looking crooked teeth overweight
hunched over like british guys they look
frail
and they don't carry guns what like
for instance for example right our cops
drive tanks carry military-style machine
guns and call in helicopters to shoot
unarmed black kids and your home pets
right like
our cops [ __ ] and awe
fear and terror why do you guys listen
to your cops like i know why people
listen to our cops i know i know why
americans are like okay okay okay
okay okay can we have cops somewhere in
the middle
like warrant or no warrant you can
search the house it's fine please don't
kill me
and then b you guys are always like i
don't understand why i have to comply
with this tom and they're like well tom
uh coveted tom uh here's a haram for um
writing you a summon storm tom tom the
police is here
tom says we're getting his summons tom
and it's like you guys just and it's
like didn't you find out they don't even
have guns
and then you see these videos of these
african uh migrants in there that like
literally like it takes like 11 of you
british cops to take down
one of them and it's like again with us
at least it's like
it's a helicopter over your house
they're yelling at you on a megaphone
there's floodlights blaring in every
window of your house they're playing
rocky like a hurricane
they're just lighting up your house
[ __ ] tannerite and [ __ ] depleted
uranium rounds
the [ __ ] cops are dressed like
futuristic stormtroopers
and i'm like oh [ __ ] why do i just don't
get why you guys listen to this dude
here okay but see this is what happened
this person got in trouble because uh
this they had
they had a bumper sticker that says
covet 19 is a lie
that's it i wish there was more
harassment in 2020 there's only one
silly
damn it and it ain't me is it not no
you know what john hello you're right
just come speak to you about the silence
yeah you're all right just come down
have a chat with me well we can talk
here can't wait
um see what i mean though you know you
know what
like you can't do that in america no no
i'll stay here at the window and we'll
talk right the [ __ ] you win
all right and that's all they do in
america he would have
shot him immediately he would have fell
out of the window
and then they would have just put a knee
in his back and been like okay so now
can we talk about the sign in your car
and you're like ow
i'm in a lot of pain
and could you tell me under what section
five public order events
yeah but under section it's likely to
cause they all they
all look like [ __ ] simon pegg movie
characters
right don't they all look like sean of
the dead
yeah and what was that other one the hot
fuzz hot fuzz they all just
looked the same over there you british
people
i i think we could all agree right like
you the british people are finished
they're done it's it's give it up it's
funny because
if that's funny you brought up hot fuzz
hot fuss shows you how bad
like the uk's police force is that
they actually had to at the end of it
give them all guns to make the movie
cool
remember how it was at the end the whole
because like the whole point of the
movie at the end was them loading up
guns and shotguns and double
shooting in the air it was like because
if not what was it going to be
and somebody that chat says merch
apparently mursh hasn't been on the
receiving end of a stern talking tour
you'd respect him a little bit more i'd
like you to come down here please so i
could finish talking to you sternly
no tom i'm going to be doing that tom
well all right then
it's an offensive you already come down
no i'm not no don't chat to me is it
well what does it matter if it is what's
your name what does that matter
because you've committed an offence i
didn't know what your name is i've
getting made a defense
that's your car is it my car
you've asked me if it were my car
this is the face of police harassment in
2020
so i've got cases against the place so i
suspect you're just here to continue
that further harassment mate
you start eating my car mate i ain't
even put petrol in it in like a week
i don't it's gas don't say i hate that
true
i'll put four liters of petrol in it
earlier
but they still do miles per hour they're
so [ __ ] weird over there
[ __ ] [ __ ] so yeah the only thing
that he did was
uh have a sticker on his car that says
coveted 19 is a lie
that's it but didn't say kova 19 is a
lie
man skip here
and and i'm gonna have to i actually
have to politely disagree with him skip
goes britain is finished because we
always follow the us
no no no no no when it comes to woke
stuff
we've been following you guys okay
do you know how many times i've heard
from people in this country
the lefties especially burning bros like
have you seen how different europe is
europe is so different man if we were
only like them
actually i'll one-up you royce how about
this skip no you know what i disagree
with roy skip
you're right you you guys founded this
country
uh remember the sun never sets on the
british empire you guys literally rule
the world and yes you're correct now you
follow us
so follow us boy follow us into [ __ ]
armageddon
boy you [ __ ] big eared crooked
toothed [ __ ]
tom sorry tom we've got to wait on the
americans tom
but wait a minute didn't we found
america we did tom but we got our asses
kicked on
turns out every time we get in trouble
tom we need the americans tom
and you just gave taiwan back a bunch of
[ __ ] losers
yeah seriously you guys literally if you
[ __ ] if you [ __ ] could hold on to
even [ __ ] one mile of land
if you weren't so good if you weren't
giving up more yards than the [ __ ]
chiefs were in the super bowl this year
okay we'd still have british palestine
we'd still have british india
we'd still have all these amazing
colonies around the world but no
you're [ __ ] you know what you are you're
patrick mahomes
with a [ __ ] grass stained jersey
that's what you are
just giving up yards getting [ __ ]
sacked every play
not cause anybody any offense distress
or alarm
you're just there to harass me further
as usual as usual mate
i know the drill by now somebody pointed
out too
yeah the english were defeated by gandhi
yeah by the way
they were defeated by gandhi without
firing a single shot
literally you guys got defeated by by
one indian who just one day
said what if we just did not go into
work
what if we just took vacation time and
british went
well i guess we give up then i guess
we've got nothing to do here let's get
out of here the indians don't want to go
to work tom
well i guess we should leave tom uh
the jacob scott show says in the chat is
a person that's fighting the cop paul
joseph watson it might be
it actually might be that's fair oh i'd
like you to know sir that i had sex with
ashton bernie and that gets me out of
the ticket
are you still on infors no uh alex
doesn't talk to me much anymore um okay
does she have a map behind you doesn't
like being upstaged
well you are harassing me you've you've
come here
somebody is okay this is great somebody
i gotta read this somebody's doing uk
insults
your mom is so fat she weighs 20 stones
[Music]
boy she did yesterday yeah all right she
did
it's hard blood please
never never trust a country that has
beans for breakfast
that's that's for me that's where i was
for breakfast and then had an entire
blood pudding pie in the toppings and
voices what you people stink
tired you know what it is man and if you
know what it is why i hate
english people because you like texans
just so
smug right but really when people start
peeling back the layers
there's not much to you other than your
smugness like
texas and england are the two places
that just have this [ __ ] pride
and then when you really go what are you
proud of they're like it's all stuff
that happened
in the past this is nothing to be proud
about now
like the alamo wait but didn't you lose
at the alamo you know like
jb has another uk joke your
refrigerator's so broken that your beer
is gold
i love uk and salts are the best uh yeah
your your mother's uh you've got
an air conditioner an apartment
we don't have those here
that an offence has been committed i
don't need to realize anything
real point in having a place these
electrical outlets are all wrong
what's wrong with you people everything
yeah guys they're electronics just
[ __ ] stink
he's the worst fast the will
of the government in it really it's the
will of the people
no it's the will of the government yeah
it is
well the will of the people is the
government [ __ ] crossing guard
because not all people in this country
support the government not all people
think it's legitimate in this country
the existence of government and the
police
well i'm here if i exist do you work
irrelevant i have to ask you officer do
you have a gun
do you have any gun or any sort of
backup
it's funny how how this because we have
a lot of uk listeners some of them are
getting a little defensive we make fun
of america more than any other gut tree
but i think it's funny somebody says
yeah because our outlets are actually
safe in the uk
your wiring is from like the [ __ ]
18th century
so they're not that safe and i don't
need a [ __ ] license to watch
tv here i could just turn tv on everyone
has a good time till it's their turn
yeah and they're like
hey wait a minute you were you were
making fun of
everyone else you know he's okay with
that but i didn't
the [ __ ] english rose whatever it is
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you guys florida has been the butt
of the joke
in this planet for so long it's
ridiculous we've been
made fun of more than anybody you guys
still have a queen i don't want to hear
it
[Music]
we do we also have a queen as well but
it's lindsey graham and it's a different
kind of queen
yeah like yeah your country's run by a
royal family
okay i get it our country's run by
jewish pedophiles i get it but at least
it's hollywood and at least they
they actually contribute to our economy
not [ __ ] suck a try
at least they make hit television shows
there's no difference in terms of my
life before or after
that's good you understand why it's a
public order offense don't you
i i am not aware of any offense being
committed
stop being silly it was being silly this
is the by the way this is a blowout
fight
this is a blowout fight if this were an
american cop and an american
the n word already been would have been
uttered five times and
forty forty rounds would have already
been found this guy's dog would be dead
yeah it would be terrible this cop would
have shot so many rounds by now that he
would have had to reload
and you can tell because this this guy
that's fighting with the cop is one of
those you know sovereign citizen people
our sovereign citizen people are [ __ ]
wild you guys are very calm
yeah someone being detained huh yeah am
i being detained
ours like act like randy marsh is dead
uh stan marsha's dad
whereas these [ __ ] guys are just well
you're being silly oh you're big city
tom
silly yes there's only one silly damn it
i love it i love the condom look can we
okay can we give
i want to give the uk something boy do
they love the work
that's a great one you guys have to use
it all the time and
i like way better than [ __ ] it is guys
get that i give you that
100 i give you but i see what you're
saying
but australians even do that better so
i'm not even giving them that much
because australians are better with the
which are the ones that lost the war to
the birds or is it australians or new
zealanders new zealand
yeah which one of you guys lost the war
to birds
and then the english lost uh a war to
literally every other creature on the
planet
yeah now
and it ain't me no it's the one wearing
a dress-up uniform thinking that they've
got some bloody authority
here and you haven't met so that's right
it's the one dressed up like a 1950s cab
the one dressed up like the cartoon taxi
from roger rabbit
you're the one who looks like an [ __ ]
man what a [ __ ] reference
you're [ __ ] you you don't i guess
that's like benny the taxi
[Laughter]
i'm not one dressed up like a cartoon
taxi cop smoking a cigar
you're the one who looks like a fool
might
why are you still stood in my garden
because i'm in a lawful business
well what we're gonna do we'll just let
the the magistrate decide not magistrate
for me to decide it's not to
decide so what we're gonna be doing is
reporting you for someone so you're
going to get a call about that
so if you claim you know who owns that
vehicle issue them as summons and they
can answer it in court
what if whoever owns that car is muslim
hey
well if he's a muslim and a african
migrant then you can't arrest him can
you talk day not only that they'd be
apologizing to them now you have to make
him mayor tom
make this black man mayor tom the
point is that i don't know who you are
you don't need to know how to work if i
told you that car belonged to a
pakistani
tom what would you do then you'd
probably just let him go wouldn't you
i'm out
you would mate you would mate
i'll have you near my cousin to
pakistani
oh i'm sorry tom did i say that was my
car i meant to say that was my
neighbor's car
oh he's a pakistani rips children and
runs around acid attacking people
so uh good luck giving him a ticket eh
[Laughter]
right so is it the owner of the vehicle
who's committed an offense
is that what you're saying yeah that's
what you've just said on video mate
i love that the cops acting frustrated
like he's the one that should be
frustrated
raybeard millennial millennials a good
point all the tough brits came to
america or got sent to australia 250
years ago
this is what's left it's just it's all
it's all the ones that were liberal
300 years ago and went why don't we get
rid of all these roughnecks
let's give it all these criminals you
know all these longshoremen hey and they
just gathered all these [ __ ] get them
out of here
and then what was left was yeah these
guys that were like i politely disagree
i politely disagree tom owner of this
vehicle
has committed an offense because i have
yeah well done do it go and do it issue
the summons to the owner of that vehicle
and get out of my face stop harassing me
you are you're making me feel distressed
and alarmed they don't sound like real
people
they don't think it's cartoon people
they sound like cartoon people
if you know who owns that vehicle issue
them with summons
and that's it are you gonna do two
minutes
what what i'm sorry i guess i should
know what ve days but i don't really
follow you guys
a little known fact i don't know if you
guys know this this cop here
was actually the homecoming king of his
high school and he won uh four male
beauty pageants
he won the mr olympia for england i
could see it he was
four-time uh mr liverpool
because that's that's the hottest guy
they have in england a ve days victory
day in europe where they celebrate the
end of world war ii
so that's what their thing is oh right
yeah because that was a victory when you
say it like that i don't believe you
no come on then
somebody says the cop was mr teen
manchester
mr teen manchester united
listen i know you were a beauty queen
tom but this is no time for this tom
hi cause you've got to show respect no
no you don't respect his earned me
respect no they didn't
they died on orders of the government
just like you
yeah get back in your van get in your
electric
amazon van and get the [ __ ] out of here
have fun getting ass and attack later by
africans hey tom
get back in your [ __ ] van you loser
it's literally an amazon delivery
it's the same fan beat it
meter maid and then he goes and reaches
into his cop
they're doubling up as amazon guys too
so then the cop walks back
he has to awkwardly walk back over here
in a minute and go hello
tom that's it's me again um do you know
uh where
apartment uh h-70s
because i've got uh i believe some
coasters tom
he just switched the best
and they go why the police delivering
amazon packages tom and he's like
well because people are ordering butter
knives on amazon tom
and the cops have to come deliver them
so we can verify age
you guys aren't allowed we can't have
people buying spoons or willy-nilly tom
you guys can't have butter knives yeah
you guys [ __ ] sucks
so bad you guys suck so bad remember the
the kid that got in trouble a few years
ago because he couldn't buy a pumpkin
carving kit
for halloween like it the things that
[ __ ] people do over there
dude you could shoot somebody in a
dispute at a bar in florida and the cops
will show up and go knock it off
beat it i don't want to see this [ __ ]
again okay
next time i come here people are getting
arrested yeah somebody's just sitting
there
holding their own and he's apologizing
the other one's going i was a mistake
man it's fine and they're like look
we're gonna get some emts out here
knock the [ __ ] off all right i'm coming
back here in an hour and
i swear to god if somebody else is shot
people are going to jail
be like sorry about that put that joint
out at least at least wait till i pull
away oh yeah
sorry i'm sorry and it take tom petty
off the jukebox
i don't want that playing when i come
back
no you guys can't even have spoons you
guys [ __ ] stink